à 16h10 je vous le disais donc nous
apprenions la mort de claude françois un
décès qui d'ores et déjà a secoué toute
une partie de la france tous ceux qui
parce qu'ils étaient parce qu'il était
de leur temps de leur époque on fait de
claude françois leur idole comme les
générations qui nous ont précédés on tue
comme idole edith piaf damian tino rossi
mistinguett ou bien maurice cheval comme
françois c'était je vous disais donc
l'idole d'une partie de la jeunesse tout
ce qui cet après midi depuis 16h10 se
sont amassés devant son domicile
boulevard exelmans en 16e
le comprenez bien ainsi et ils étaient
nombreux très nombreux
je vous propose de retrouver sur place
notre reporter jean jacques dufour ans
le chanteur qui allait avoir 40 ans et
mort de l'accident le plus stupide qui
soit il est mort électrocuté au 8e étage
dans son appartement
les quelques proches présents sont
consternés il attendait le chanteur sur
un plateau de télévision
quand ils ont appris ce soir claude
françois avait organisé un dîner
ici au 46 boulevard exelmans cette mort
a surpris tout le monde
il est 15 heures claude françois quitte
sa terrasse où il profite des premiers
rayons de soleil de l'année il à chaud
il se rend dans la salle de bain la une
ampoule marche mal claude françois et
ses de la changer et il s'écroule
la jeune femme avec qui il vit appelle
immédiatement les pompiers
ceci pour un massage cardiaque le coeur
repart malheureusement il s'arrêtera à
nouveau et définitivement
il est environ 15h
lucien salle son nouvel agent me disais
tout à l'heure
sa manie du perfectionnisme toujours
vouloir que tout marche parfaitement
bien depuis que la nouvelle est
officielle
des barrières ont été installées autour
du domicile quelques admiratrices en
pleurs et des badauds 200 peut-être sans
groupés derrière sur un banc en face de
l'immeuble des inscriptions un peu
désuète comme à toi claude pour la vie
la mère du chanteur viendra tout à
l'heure elle n'était pas à paris cet
après midi claude françois avait deux
enfants
[Musique]